it's it's very easy to assume that we
all experience the world the same way
you're wearing a kind of mauve purple
shirt and a blue shirt and it seems like
that's out there in the world those
colors are out there in the world
they're not being made up in my head but
that's not true we don't see the world
as it is we see it as we are so there's
some classic studies about the effective
language that native Russian speakers
distinguish more shades of blue to these
categories are imposed in a slightly
different way if we see things in a
different way then we're talking about
two different realities yeah in a sense
I've been fond of saying that our
experience is like a controlled
hallucination we have these social media
Echo Chambers but we also have to some
extent perceptual Echo Chambers too you
know we all live in different in a world
unique inner world and we'll probably
seek out perceptual information to
reinforce the way we encounter the world
even at these these lowest levels and
what's out there who knows ask a
physicist the way we experience it is
always coming from the inside out
foreign
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is a professor of
neuroscience at the University of Sussex
and author of a best-selling book being
you a new science of Consciousness Anil
Seth welcome to trigonometry thanks for
having me it's a pleasure to be here
it's great to have you on the show uh
before we get into the main interview
tell everybody a little bit about who
you are obviously neuroscientist but how
are you where you are what has been the
journey through life that leads you to
be sitting here talking to us I've
always been interested in one of these I
think fundamental Mysteries which is
this mystery of Consciousness and I
think it's a mystery that even before
you put a name to it appears when when
we're all kids like who am I why am I me
and not somebody else where was I before
I was born what happens to me after I
die and then as I as I got older these
that basic question evolved into deeper
questions like how is it possible that
this lump of electrified Pate inside my
head can give rise to an experience you
know an experience of the world the
redness of red the Pang of an emotional
experience the sense of free will and
it's not that I set out with this plan
to be an academic researching this stuff
I just kind of never lost interest in it
and gradually wound my way through
different disciplines at University and
afterwards studying psychology and
physics and then computer science
and uh by about 20 years ago when I'd
finished my PhD around that time the
study of Consciousness was was coming
back onto the radar in Academia in
neuroscience and psychology and
philosophy and so I was lucky to to get
a position back at University of Sussex
I went I did my PhD there I went to
America for a few years California and
came back and and started a group trying
to understand how the brain works but
specifically trying to understand this
big question of how and why we
experience the world and the self the
way we do and also what applications
this understanding can have for for
medicine for mental health and neurology
fit for technology how we develop and
interact with with AI and and also for
society as a whole understanding how we
perceived the world and how we perceive
ourselves I think has a lot of
implications for society in general so
that's kind of how I got yeah well it
sounds like you've taken like a
childhood passion and just kept going
until you became quite successful in
that field and that's why it's
interesting to have you on so
what is consciousness
people will disagree for me it's very
simple we all know what Consciousness is
it's what goes away when you fall into a
dream this sleep or go under general
anesthesia which if you've done that
have you been under generalities so you
know it's like it's completely different
from sleep isn't it I mean you you have
no idea how much time has passed
certainly the times I've had General you
you go under you come back
and you're not just sort of dozing
you're just not there it could be 10
years later it could be 10 years later
and it's stacked it's that Oblivion
that's it's um that is unconsciousness
and the flip side of that is is
consciousness so when that's not
happening you are conscious
the the philosopher Tom Thomas Nagel
puts it I think very nicely he says for
a conscious organism there is something
it is like to be
that organism like it feels like
something to be you or me probably many
animals it feels like something to be
that animal but for for you under
general anesthesia or for a table or a
chair
there's nothing going on there's no
subjective experience going on at all so
that's Consciousness so what but see
forgive me but to me that's quite an
unsatisfying way of describing it
because I suppose what I'm so I thought
I imagine as part of that yep and also
then experience whatever that is
physical you know emotional that's all
Consciousness right
right so I think I think you can yeah
that's a starting point just just yeah
so that definition is is useful partly
because of what it excludes so it's
saying Consciousness is not the same
thing as as intelligence it's not the
same thing as having language or of
behaving in a particular way it's just
any kind of experience but what does
that you know what does that mean how do
you work with that so the way I approach
it is to think of like three different
aspects of Consciousness that cover this
broad idea one of them is is level like
what happens in the brain when you you
lose Consciousness entirely like in
anesthesia or in other conditions
something that affects globally how
conscious you are then there's conscious
content which is
when you are conscious you're conscious
of something you open your eyes and a
world is there and has colors and shapes
and people and places and objects and
things are happening and how does that
occur because the brain can take in
information and respond to it without
Consciousness being involved we can
perceive things unconsciously not
everything that that reaches our senses
we as uh affects what we're aware of so
what in the brain
generates the experience of a world and
then finally
what in the brain underpins the
experience of the self because it's it's
it's tempting to think of the self as
like you just take it for granted it's
this it's this mini me inside my brain
somewhere that is doing all the
perceiving and then deciding what to do
next
but the way I think in a lot of others
in this area think is that the self
is not the thing that does the
perceiving it's not something to be
taken for granted itself is another kind
of perception the brain is creating the
experience of Self in the same way that
it's creating the experience of the
world I think dividing it this way gives
gives um certainly that's what
structures the way I do my research I
try and understand these areas they're
all joined up in some ways but you can
approach them at least a little bit
separately I feel like I'm high again
and so it's not been the case so we all
experience Consciousness yeah so why is
our Consciousness different and how
different is our Consciousness if you
see what I mean
yeah I think this is a really I mean
this is in fact something we're working
on at the moment
um
it's it's very easy to assume that we
all experience the world the same way
because our experience
has that character you know I open I'm
looking at you guys now and you're
wearing a kind of mauve purple shirt and
a blue shirt and it seems like
that's out there in the world those
colors are out there in the world
they're not being made up in my head and
the same for everything else I'm
experiencing
but that's not true right the the way
it's actually working is of course
there's a real world out there of course
you guys are actually out there and
they're a thing there are these objects
that you're sitting on and wearing
um but the way
I or anybody or any animal would
experience them is dependent partly on
what's there but to a large extent on
what
how the brain decides to make sense of
it colors are really good example you
know you take a piece of white paper
from in here outside and it still looks
white even though the light waves
bouncing into your eyes have changed
completely the brain takes into account
all the ambient Lighting in order to
decide what color something should be
and the same hap the same is true for
everything that we experience which
means that we're all gonna experience
things differently
even though
we even though it seems as though we see
the world just as it truly is
and sometimes these differences can be
quite large and sometimes people see
things that other people don't you know
they start actively hallucinating
um or they might have what we would call
a neurodivergent condition where some
autism or ADHD or something so their
experience of the world is quite
dramatically different in a way that can
often be challenging
but I think and there's some evidence
for this now that that even if you don't
hallucinate actively or describe
yourself as neurodivergent we all
experience the world differently in fact
there's no sort of single true way to
experience it you know our perceptions
are tied to reality otherwise they would
be useless but there's but they're
always a construction and the
constructions will always differ
quite how much they differ is something
that we we're looking at we have this
project called the perception census
which is
a set of online little brain teasers and
interactive experiments and illusions
that is trying to map out this Hidden
World of of inner diversity
because you know I think we know in
society that we've come to hopefully
optimistically
cherish the externally visible diversity
we have in in sort of high skin color
and and so on and cultural background
that we can see on the outside
uh and so I think recognizing and
learning to to cherish the inner
diversity that we have too could be
equally transformational but we just
need to know what it looks like that's
such a profound point the inner
diversity because how much of this inner
diversity Anil is
chemical biological whatever way you
want to put it and also how much of it
is a product of our childhood
experiences and our culture and what we
have been taught growing up this is a
very good question and I don't think
there's going to be any single clear
answer to it we're all you know as
individuals this complicated mix of
inheritance you know what's in our genes
development how we grew up the childhood
experiences the culture the language we
speak
um and just what happened to me
yesterday is going to affect how I
encountered the world and the self today
teasing these things apart is very very
difficult but there's some clues that
that can help us so there's some classic
studies about the effect of language
that native Russian speakers distinguish
more shades of blue so you're a native
Russian speaker so probably I mean you
know like the the light wave spectrum
the electromedic spectrum is basically
just a continuous
set of light of wavelengths yes but but
our brains carve it up into distinct
colors which is why a rainbow has these
distinct bands it doesn't just look like
a continuous band of color
um
but that's our brains imposing these
categories
and it turns out that for Native Russian
speakers these categories are imposed in
a slightly different way
entirely useless here because the sky is
always good the sky's always great this
is true yeah but but it's one example of
how you know language
um I've always thought this you know
like I noticed that when my wife and I
if we're speaking Russian versus when
we're speaking English I I am speaking
Russian or English to people if I'm I've
always thought the language is identity
to some extent because I am a different
person when I'm speaking Russian to when
I'm speaking English I say things
differently it's almost I almost would
say I have slightly different opinions
interesting when when I am in the
different I don't know if you find this
yeah yeah I find it because um I
wouldn't say I'm a native Spanish
speaker but I learned Spanish at the
same time I learned English right but I
I feel that way when I speak Spanish I'm
more demonstrative I'm more open and
then when I speak English I'm all kind
of I also speak I speak Spanish but not
as well as you I learned it as a sort of
the late teenager embarrassed about my
inability to speak anything but English
and I think yeah that I feel just much
more stupid when I speak Spanish though
badly it does seem to affect the
thoughts it's not just the ability to
express our thoughts I start having
simpler thoughts about where the bus
station is what's on the menu
yeah so one of the interesting things
that I always saw and you know this idea
that perception is projection right
essentially to something to a large
extent that's that's kind of a part of
almost every spiritual tradition as part
of if you do personal development this
is the first thing they'll teach you you
know you are projecting your crap
basically onto the world and then you're
upset at what's coming back at you so
what what does that what does it mean
particularly because as you say when we
look out into the world the world is
it's an infinite amount of information
and is it the case that the reason we
have we see certain things is like I am
Pro like right now there's a wealth of
information behind you but I'm looking
at you yeah because you're a human being
and I'm seeing certain things about you
that I'm primed to receive
um and so we're all essentially creating
our own experience for us for ourselves
yeah I think that's right I think
you're quite right a lot of traditions
whether it's in in Western culture
personal development or in eastern
spiritual Traditions especially Buddhism
and the concept of Maya and that things
are illusory and their surface
appearance there's a lot of
um a long history to thinking this way
that what we experience is a kind of
projection but what I think Neuroscience
is bringing to the table is instead of
this being metaphorical it's it's
unpacking it literally like how does
this actually happen how deep does it go
what does it mean in terms of some of
our more basic encounters with the world
just our experience of of shape and
color for instance you know that's not
given that's also a projection
and what's literally happening at least
you know I think and this is the idea
that I've been exploring in my work and
in the book is that the brain is a kind
of prediction engine yes
and instead of just passively soaking up
information from the world or the body
yeah the information that comes in is is
ambiguous it's noisy it's just this as
you say this almost infinite morass of
of signals whether it's electromagnetic
radiation or sound waves or whatever it
might be the brain has to make sense of
this to conjure
there's a definite world a world that
just sort of clicks into position it's
things that we see
and so the way it does that it has to
actively interpret the information that
it gets
and how does it do that well here's what
here's what the theory says the theory
says that
the brain is constantly throwing out
predictions about the likely causes of
sensory signals like what's most likely
to be out there in the world to give
rise to the information that's coming in
and then it uses the sensory information
to calibrate its predictions to update
them to tune them to the world
and what we perceive is not a readout of
the signals it's the content of the of
the predictions
so just zooming out a little bit again
what this means is our our experiences
are not just passive registrations of an
objective reality they're always active
top down inside out constructions we
actively generate our worlds and we also
I think the same goes for the body too
you know our emotional responses are
perceptions of what's happening to the
body in response to the world I think
this is this really for me this keeps
nagging at me where even just in
everyday life because we walk around and
it just seems as though we see the world
in this kind of we're reading it from
the from the outside in and it's
continually challenging
counter-intuitive to think that's that's
not what's going on you know we're we're
always you know what's out there who
knows ask a physicist but the way we
experience it is always coming from the
inside out that's very interesting and
of course anyone who's looked into this
for a half a second knows it's true and
on the other hand I feel like that puts
that makes it quite difficult to live
life in a way because it's like I I get
that I'm projecting my thoughts and
whatever onto reality so how do I then
navigate the world because like I know
for example if I jump out of that window
I am going to hit the ground like that's
real right if I drive my car into
something that's a bad outcome for me
and for the car and for whatever so how
do we how do we navigate reality then
what knowing all of this how does this
change the way we live life
unfortunately Evolution has designed the
way the brain constructs our experience
so that we don't do things like jump out
of Windows or drive cars into walls I've
been fond of saying that our experience
is like a controlled hallucination it's
a hallucination in the sense that it is
generated by the brain but it's the
control is equally important so
Evolution has shaped
our perceptual mechanisms our brain
circuitry so that
the experiences we have
tied to the world in ways that are very
useful for guiding our lives for
survival in the broader sense of the
work of the word
so this means also that we're likely to
have some somewhat well substantially
similar experiences yes we might
experience slightly different shades of
red but unless you're like actively
frankly hallucinating we all look out of
the window and see there's a big drop
and we know that that's a bad thing to
you know to Just Launch ourselves into
so I think that's I think that's fine I
think that
actually the novelist the nice and
inside it very well she said we don't
see the world as it is we see it as we
are and evolution has made sure that we
see things as we are in a way that's
usually aligned with what we need to do
to survive of course this is this is a
challenge in some respects because you
know we have Technologies now where
we're unable to sense some things which
might be damaging to us like radiation
for instance we we just don't detect it
that's not part of our uh our controlled
hallucination Evolution didn't shape us
to be sensitive to these kinds of things
and then we might also perceive you know
other things like the the rate of change
of carbon in the atmosphere we're very
bad at perceiving things that unfold
over time scales that Evolution hasn't
deemed relevant to our ongoing survival
and you know in the world in which we
live
our perceptual tuning is becoming less
adequate to the challenges we face but
it's still perfectly adequate to the the
here and now to like the not jumping out
of Windows or running in front of buses
isn't that the problem as well that
essentially we're all on social media
and social media has been designed
almost to hack our very Consciousness so
that we judge our success and failure in
life by what is happening in this
virtual world yeah I think it's it's
amplifies and we're we're very familiar
I think from social media with this idea
of social media Echo Chambers right I
mean we seek out
news that confirms what we already think
there are this drives the Dynamics of
polarization
and we we enter this situation where it
becomes very hard to to even understand
that another person can have the beliefs
that they have
because uh sort of the way our own
beliefs has been shaped have have been
rooted in in very different sources of
of information
and I think you can almost draw a
parallel here with perception too yes we
have these social media Echo Chambers
but we also have to some extent
perceptual Echo Chambers too you know we
all live in different in a world unique
in a world right down to the level of
how we experience them and we'll
probably seek out
perceptual information to reinforce the
way we encounter the world even at these
these lowest levels how do you solve
that I I this is an enormous challenge
but of course
recognizing that we live in Echo
Chambers is essential prerequisite to
overcoming the problems that they pose
right if you don't know you live in more
if you don't know you live in a bubble
you'll never get out of it
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
and then therefore the question is if we
all experience reality in inverted
commas subjectively
then
is there any such thing as truth really
you know people argue about the truth
and this is the truth
is there any such thing as the truth
well it's a very loaded term right I
mean it can mean different things in in
in different contexts if you think about
2000 you know objective reality I I it's
true to say that we're all sitting on
chairs right but then a physicist might
come along and say well you know of
course a chair is just an approximation
for a bunch of atoms behaving in a
particular way and there's no such thing
as a chair and Wittgenstein would come
along and say the whole concept of chair
is is a problem you know there's just a
sort of vague category of chairness
um but for those of us who are not that
clever I mean we can also agree you know
what I mean so that's what I mean I
think there's you know there's a there's
a level of Truth which is just you know
the right level of consensus which has
you know which which is reinforced by by
experience so yeah it is true that we're
all sitting on chairs I think that's
fine so the fact that we all
construct our experiences doesn't mean
that we have to get rid of the concept
of Truth and that nothing is true no I
didn't that's right yeah I guess what
I'm getting at I'm curious is this will
be a shocking example but like is there
a difference between us consensually
agreeing that we're sitting on chairs
and people in Nazi Germany agreeing that
the Jews are evil like is there a
difference between that or is that just
people creating this objective
consensual reality based on what's going
on inside I think there's a I think
there's a massive difference forget
morality I'm just talking about a
practical level but I think I think yeah
because the the fact that we're sitting
on chairs is something that can be
immediately verified by the fact that
you know you sit down and you don't
immediately fall through onto the floor
yeah and and the consequences of our
belief that we're sitting on a chair is
just reinforced
by what happens next
as you get further and further away from
the ability to
test your perceptual beliefs against
reality then they become then they can
become more and more divorced and so I
don't think you can
get away the the key difference there is
morality you know you that idea the idea
about what not what people and some
people in Nazi Germany thought about
Jews is a moral ethical position and you
that is not something the truth of which
is established like sitting on a chair
it's clearly wrong anyway but that kind
of claim even if it was a morally good
claim even if it was a different kind of
claim that you know the the claim that
you know everybody should be free to
marry whoever they want or something
like that that's not something that can
be verified in the same way that sitting
on a chair right can be verified so
there is a difference and and since we
are on the subject of politics I suppose
the question that we end up with you
mentioned polarization we've obviously
had an awful amount of it in recent
years
um
is there any point having political
discussions
seems to be our only chance right I mean
one of the language
is one of the most probably the most
distinctive features of the human
species and we like to think as humans
we're special and we usually think we're
more special than we actually are in a
whole history of of science I think has
been a history of of deflating this
human exceptionalism and realizing that
we're more continuous with with the rest
of nature than was previously thought
the language I still think is is
distinctive
for humans and it gives us so much
potential in both directions it's
language that allows us to build culture
build civilization but of course it's
language also that can be uh can can be
used to bootstrap these dynamics of
polarization
I I don't know I mean it's it's
sometimes it seems fruitless doesn't it
but it does but what else are you going
to do yeah do you sometimes sing a nil
that because so early on in the year I
did a mushroom ceremony or where I took
magic mushrooms and then I took a
tobacco as well and I had very powerful
hallucinations and people said to me
like what was the experience of that
and the reality is is that language
isn't enough at times do you think
that's also part of the challenge that
we're experiencing this Consciousness
and we have this marvelous tool that is
language but sometimes it isn't enough
to adequately convey our emotions in the
way that we perceive the world I think
that's absolutely right I mean this is
why we still have a space for literature
isn't it I mean there's something about
good writing that can evoke uh an
experience a setting
um more than most of us are able to do
with words but I think there is still a
fundamental limit because this is almost
a necessary trade-off with language
we it has to gloss over fine
distinctions in order to be useful at
all if if I had a word and this gets
back to the fact that we might
experience the world in subtly different
ways without even going as far as a
mushroom ceremony
um
if there was a separate word for every
possible experienceable shade of blue
then we would be using different words
and we would never
communicate so it's the fact that
language
abstracts away from the fine details of
experience that's actually what makes it
useful yeah because we can then
communicate but the trade-off is is as
you say language will not
capture
fine grain of experiences and there are
some experiences like like psychedelics
um that will really challenge
the boundaries of What language can can
achieve but this is perhaps why you know
sometimes these kinds of experiences can
be quite valuable because they provide
first person sort of
kick you know they've heard of first
person opportunity to realize that the
the world we experience is a
construction of the brain that it's not
just a direct window onto the way the
world is it can open a gap I think
between our lived experience and how we
relate to that in the same way that
meditation can do as well but over much
longer time scales with much more
practice do you think that's part of the
problem as well is that
we all since we all experience a world
in a different way
it makes it's so much more tricky to be
harmonious because if we see things in a
different way then
we're talking about two different
realities yeah in a sense I mean you
remember that that photo from a few
years ago of the dress yeah that was
half the world saw as blue and black and
half a yellow and white
and that's a great allegory for your
point isn't it because I mean the
division over that was extraordinary and
it was just a photo of a dress but
people could not understand that it was
possible to see it another way because
it seemed to them that they were seeing
it as it really is
and so that does you know you put that
in a more contentious context rather
than just the color of a photo of a
dress tax policy yeah yeah or strikes
whatever and yeah you're going to get
into trouble and um I think that's part
of the reason why
this recognition about how perception
Works how quantity experience works it's
not just sort of of mere scientific
interest it's a direct social relevance
because we need to understand when you
kind of bed in this understanding as
widely as possible
that perception is you know it's
dependent on us we see things as we are
and to cultivate a little bit of
humility about our perceptual encounters
with the world which this is me being a
bit sort of optimistic and panglossian
you know my
end up in cultivating a bit of humility
also about our beliefs
and allow us to you know if if we can
get people for instance imagine this
imagine you have people disagreeing
violently about some political issue and
you get them to sit down and look at
this photo of the dress
and they see it different ways but then
you kind of take them through how and
why they see it different ways and the
fact that it's a construction and so on
you know would that process of
understanding the nuts and bolts of
perspective taking you know would that
give them a better platform for
communicating about the beliefs they
violently disagree about I don't know
but maybe well speaking of contentious
issues I suppose one of the most obvious
questions here is well there's two
questions actually uh first of all
human beings throughout our history have
had some kind of belief on the Supreme
Being or a set of Supreme Beings or
super whatever you know some version of
that
um do you have any insight as to why we
do this is it because we are connected
to a Supreme Being that exists is it
because our brain produces you know what
can you tell us about that part first of
all I think this is it's it's such a
common feature of of human culture isn't
it of course to everybody of different
cultures have their own different
Supreme Beings this is where a lot of
the trouble starts
um
and but I think you asked the right
question why are we compelled across
cultures to have some belief that that
that fits that description
and this is a little bit out of my
wheelhouse but the the intuition I have
is it's really something to do with the
fact that we
um might be two things going on first is
perhaps another distinct maybe this
isn't distinctive about humans but we
know we are mortal you know we know we
will die at least we know that in the
abstract it's very hard to actually
understand what that means
um and in the face of that
now we have that conflict with what
evolution over millions and millions of
years has shaped brains to do which is
to persist to keep the body alive
and that basic kind of operating system
of our of our psychology to continue to
keep on going it's just incompatible
with the knowledge that at some point we
don't and
to resolve that that contradiction you
know we need something and one of the
things that that comes up is um is a
Supreme Being I think the other
interesting idea about this and this is
not my idea at all I can't remember
where I where I first read this was that
the concept of of a God or a Supreme
Being came about as human society
um
changed in ways that groups of the
groups of people living together got
stronger and stronger got bigger and
bigger rather so that in order to um to
reinforce this the hierarchies to allow
larger groups of people to to keep on to
keep going together without sort of
dissolving into content with the shared
myth so you'll know the Ferrari for
example yeah that's probably I mean and
I don't think it's very hard to find any
evidence for that but you you know some
appeal to something Beyond a single
individual human
seems in principle that can reinforce
hierarchies very very strongly I don't
know whether it's true I tend to think
it's the it's this distinction but it's
this tension between knowledge of our
mortality and the deeply baked in drive
to stay alive that's at the heart of it
and it's the second question that's
interesting to me is whether it's
psychedelics whether it's spiritual
experiences that I've had where talking
to other people about certain things I I
got the sense very strongly that when
people experience that freedom of this
constant brain processing the immediate
surroundings and whatever quite often
they all have the experience of ultimate
connection with other people and the the
universe whatever that is do we have any
thoughts on on whether that where that
comes from I think so yeah I think this
is something where Neuroscience might
shed a bit of light on because it it
goes back to earlier part of our
conversation about what is the self now
the idea there's the the sort of
immediate really superficially appealing
idea that the self is this immutable
essence of you or me that's just there
and might survive after death or
whatever
um compared to
this other view of the self that it's
it's a perception that it's it's a
construction of the brain and um and
might change over time as well the way
we experience being a self is not fixed
it does evolve even though we don't
necessarily perceive it evolving
and if it's a construction of the brain
it can also be tuned down or even go
away
and there's this concept from meditation
from some psychedelics research as well
from some spiritual Traditions about ego
dissolution
and I think again this is not
necessarily A metaphorical thing it can
be quite grounded in
a way
of conscious experience happening in
which the experience of self is either
absent or at least attenuated to a great
degree
one of the things the brain does I think
when in normal everyday life it leads to
people in our culture is it's always
um establishing distinctions between
self and other whether it's other people
or the rest of the world now these
distinctions are not
not complete and and they're very fluid
like part of what it means to be me is
how I experience myself
refracted through the minds of others
there's there's part of me is really
residing in in the minds of my my
friends and colleagues and so on
um but you know at the same time I see
this hand in front of me I know that's
my hand those hands are not this chair
is not part of my body there are some
aspects of the construction of self
which which impose a relatively clear
distinction but those distinctions you
know can be done away with it doesn't
mean they go away in the real world like
my body is still separate from the chair
but the brain might in some in some
states it might not draw these
distinctions in perception
and that could be what's going on that
underlies this experience of
connectedness and in fact if you look
inside the brains of people on on high
doses of psychedelics you see things
compatible with that idea you see sort
of more mixing of the brain circuits
whereas typically there's sort of
there's parts of the brain that are more
associated with self and when they're
active other parts of the brain more
associated with experience of the world
you know they tend to be largely
separable but under psychedelics
everything gets a bit mushed together so
so it's when when the self the self is
reduced in so prominence that's when our
ability to connect with other things
becomes stronger essentially is that
well I think that's when we have the I
think there's a difference here between
ability and experience yeah so there's
we enter a state where we suddenly feel
more connected with other people with
the universe in general with the Stars
with the trees with the grass and so on
um but if experience is partly
projection I would imagine then in that
state you're much more likely to behave
with other people in a way that makes it
easier to connect I mean I know this
experientially like the less self the
more I can we can we can connect maybe I
think it might it might be a sort of a
balancing act right I think if you if
you're in a total state of ego
dissolution then then the concept of
interaction becomes a bit pointless
because there's no you anymore at all so
it's about finding the balance and I
think the the value of
of transient experiences of of things
like ego dissolution is that when you
come back out of the other side you
relate to your everyday self and
therefore others in a bit of a different
way but it's still yeah it's still back
so we we talk about hallucinations and
in a sense this is a hallucination
there's um well we all know I'm the
music producer Pharrell who says that he
sees music certain notes of certain
colors and what does that mean then in
terms of the evolution hallucinations in
terms of creativity do are created
people as the the con the same goes like
they're more volatile they're more
passionate
is that such a thing do they tend to
feel things more deeply do they tend to
see a different type of hallucination
I think it's very hard to pin down what
the secret source of creativity is you
know people can be creative in all sorts
of different ways
but there are in individual cases I
think you can see that specific
and interestingly different ways of
experiencing the world can be a spark
that fuels one person's creativity I
mean the phenomenon you're describing
there is called synesthesia which is
super interesting it's like a broadly
speaking it's a mixing of the senses and
for most of us
vision and hearing you know that they're
separate right if I hear a sound it
might conjure up a particular image in
my mind but I don't literally see things
but in synesthesia
the connection is much more clear is
much closer and people indeed different
notes can evoke experiences of
particular colors and that's one form of
synesthesia tastes can have shapes there
are many forms of mixing the senses
I mean even for us even for
non-synasties the senses mix in some
ways like this is what we call metaphor
you know some notes are high others are
low and and
um taster sharp or or dull I mean we
we don't yeah we encounter our world as
a mixture of Senses anyway but for
synesthesia it's it's like more direct
and there's good examples of of
musicians and Painters Kandinsky there's
a synesthes the novelist Vladimir nabo
coffee wrote Lolita was a synesthete
and this is understandable right you
have a different way of encountering the
world that that can provide associations
that other people don't have and that
being the case at what point does these
types of conditions go into something
like mental illness with schizophrenia
where people are seeing things or
perceiving the world in ways which are
just completely have no bearing on
reality so this this site gets back to
this idea of perceptual diversity and
this this Continuum or spectrum that we
might think of and um most of us live in
the middle bit you know just as most of
us are between I don't know like
nearly five feet and six feet or
whatever of height you know most of us
will see the world in in different ways
but in ways which is still well adapted
to what's really out there and
sufficiently similar that we can
communicate but you know as you go
further off that then you get into the
territory where you might start to
ascribe people either with something
like a neurodiversion condition or with
something like a mental illness
um but the key Point here is that the
fact that you experience the world
differently does not in itself mean
that there's a deficit or that there's a
particular condition or it doesn't
mental illness going on now that's
something that happens when your way of
seeing something
poses challenges for the environment you
live in like even something like
schizophrenia
which is very very distressing for
people that experience it you know you
hear voices in your head that are
instructing you to do things often it's
a lot of auditory hallucinations you
feel dissociated from yourself
you know In some cultures these uh these
experiences were sort of celebrated as
somebody you know channeling some
spiritual energy rather than being
thought of as mentally ill
uh
and
hopefully the the recognition that we
all construct our experiences we all
differ in some ways
gives us a greater empathy for people
who are mentally ill in one way or
another
um that's at least the hope and also
just sorry one other point on this is
that
there's plenty of people who hallucinate
who are on you know out of that middle
range who aren't mentally ill there's a
hearing voices for instance is actually
quite common for people I can't I'm not
sure what the statistics are I have a
colleague Charles Fernie Hoff and darum
who's LED this um project called the
hearing voices project
to understand like how widespread it is
um because for most people if they hear
a voice in their head you know they
there's a great taboo against talking
about it because you don't want to be
labeled as as suffering psychosis or as
mad or mentally ill
it's only a problem when these voices
become a problem in virtue of what
they're saying for some people they're
just kind of benign if they're saying go
to the gym like that's fine yeah exactly
and visual Hallucination is the same
some people see things but it's not
always distressing or problematic so the
range of altered experiences I think is
much much broader much richer than we
typically think so I find that very
interesting because I have ADHD and I
remember when I got diagnosed with it I
entered not a period of morning it's a
strong way I put it but almost a week of
just sadness really when I received the
diagnosis and then it's it's a process
of understanding with myself in that the
way I see the world in the way that I
move through the world is very different
to the way other people do and as a
result it's not just an acceptance of
myself but it's also
how can I put this a journey to try and
understand other people so that we can
meet halfway do you see what I mean yeah
yeah yeah and and I think that's a
really important way of looking at it
because if you just go down the path of
well this is me the world needs to
change around me the world is never
going to do that right and you have to
accept that but if you find a way for
you to sell to
be able to exist more cohesively with
the world I think that's how you get
again a greater sense of acceptance do
you see what I mean yeah and I think I
think the bar should be higher than
acceptance as well and here you know I
come to this metaphor of biodiversity
like in in ecosystems we are we're just
aware that having lots of different
kinds of plants and animals is a good
thing for a flourishing ecosystem you
don't want a monoculture
and I think exactly the same is true for
human cultures and whether this is
diversity on the outside again skin
color and whatever but especially
diverse than the inside it's not that
well I think that's much more important
actually yeah definitely yeah and you
want to get to a point where differences
in the way we encounter the world are
not merely accommodated but in Rich
Society well if you think about the fact
I mean Francis talks about ADHD most
comedians have come out as having ADHD
in the last year just for some reason
but it kind of makes sense like if
Francis is brilliant when we do our live
streams at like making random jumps from
one thing to another I imagine the ADHD
is part of that and there'll be other
conditions that fuel other forms of
creativity and and whatever they're not
maybe even a condition they're just a
way of a different way of being in the
world which has trade-offs right as all
ways of being uh do
hey Francis what is the best way to
advertise a business oh I see you see
all you need to do is spend tons of cash
on a radio advert that advert is
guaranteed to be heard by people who are
completely disengaged and not even
properly listening then simply sit back
and watch all your hard-earned money go
up in Flames hmm what about advertising
with trigonometry why would I do that
when I can advertise on [__] FM for the
measly sum of 30 000 pounds and generate
precisely zero sales because
trigonometry now has nearly a million
subscribers across all Platforms in
January alone we generated over 12 and a
half million views and downloads that's
right you can buy an ad with us and
we'll promote your business on one of
our incredible episodes we'll match your
brand with the most suitable episode
that way you know it has every chance of
being a success plus your advert will be
ridden by two professional comedians
that's right we're hiring two
professional comedians we pride
ourselves on making our ads funny and
engaging to the point that some people
say they're their favorite part of the
show yeah we probably shouldn't admit
that mate yeah you're right all you need
to do is contact us on marketing at
triggerpod.co.uk that's marketing add
triggerpod.co.uk advertise with us and
we will get your business noticed by the
most problematic people on planet Earth
so I'm curious to come back to the
political side of the conversation
because I'm just wondering you know
how because on the one hand you could
say well look people have their own
version of reality and and that's just
what it is and that's fine but yet we do
go through like
periods don't we you know you have
Thatcher and there's a particular way of
seeing the world and then you have you
know Blair and there's a particular way
seeing the world and then you have the
current gov and there are philosophical
and political ways of looking at the
world that change over time
and at the same time you know if you
read more about history actually the the
political battle between the sort of
more Lefty more compassion more empathy
but perhaps slightly less uh of the
rationality and pragmatism versus the
overly rational overly pragmatic lacking
in empathy that's been going on since
since forever right so how do we how do
we navigate the political world I mean
like you know I'm doing question time
tomorrow is there any point of me saying
anything
well this is you you asked earlier about
what's the value of political
conversation I think you know make
making these points is exactly is what's
needed I mean there are some currents as
you say that that have just almost
always been there some tensions between
individualism and collectivism yeah and
politics very very broadly
and um
the pendulum the pendulum swings and the
pendulum swings for all sorts of reasons
right partly because people tend to
react against a status quo people have
short short memories
um people always are attracted to change
um for change sake often so this this
sets up you know dynamic where it's very
hard to retain stability and it looks
like you know we're leaving one period
and maybe entering another period now
after whatever 12 years of in Western
politics seems to have this kind of this
kind of cycle
um
and think what's really helpful is
trying to get on you probably can't stop
that from happening but you know
nonetheless there might be some shared
core beliefs that that can be built on
now what I really personally find
troubling about politics is this kind of
Tit for Tat responsive thing rather than
the the inability to build on
previous positions previous political
eras in a way that's cumulative even if
it might not seem like it because
whether you're on the left or the right
in England for instance or the UK you
probably still have some core beliefs
about access to healthcare and so on
people should have some and what why
can't we still find those areas of
consensus and build on them without too
much just doing something and then
undoing it and doing something else and
then undoing it and going back and forth
well it seems like that's happening
because we're all too attached to the
ideas that our particular interpretation
of reality is the one true thing and
anyone who disagrees with it is a
heretic and must be you know canceled
destroyed evil whatever you know that
seems to me to be quite a big part of it
probably driven by social media to a
large extent uh although I imagine you
know political debate has always been
fraught and and uh sometimes violent
actually right I mean it's getting a lot
more peaceful than it has done over
history and I think there's people like
Stephen Pinker who did quite a good job
of pointing out yeah in fact there are a
lot of things that are getting better
even though it really doesn't seem like
it and again partly because of
how the media's attention works the
things that change slowly don't tend to
get much much Focus things that change
quickly and dramatically do tend to get
Focus
and I think in the same in the same way
the differences between positions tend
to attract attention rather than the
commonalities
between positions and one of the things
that I've been quite surprised at as
I've gotten older is
is actually the consensus between
different political parties on things
because you just don't hear about it in
the media and you tend to assume that
that everything is is treated
differently but it's not always the case
that is a really interesting point and
of course you're right that people uh
want change often for the sake of it I
remember
um I can't remember who it was but there
was a period when there was quite a lot
of uh agreement and concordance between
the positions of the labor party and the
conservative party and what happened you
get people from the left like George
gallo and people from the right like
Nigel farage coming along and saying
well it's Tweedledee and twiddle done
there is no there's no difference
between the two cheeks of the same
backside and people are clamoring then
for a new way of doing things when there
is that consensus so I guess this is
kind of The Human Condition isn't it we
go around in these circles yeah and I
think you see this especially now with
the rise of identity politics you know
people needing to to have almost as an
extension of their experience of self
you know the the you have the boy body
you have the perspective sense of will
you have your social network and then
you know you need a political self too
and you know this is
again something that can be valuable
because it can serve to
to highlight underrepresented groups
this is a valuable thing but taken again
taken too far it becomes just a bit
a bit pointless really because
[Music]
again it emphasizes the differences
rather than the commonalities you're
disconnecting yourself from other people
yeah yeah yeah so what role does
hormones or do hormones play in this in
the need for try to become part of the
tribe in the need to you know have a
group and also have an enemy which was
which is literally hardwired into us
it's a survival mechanism
I it's a really good question it's it's
a I mean I don't know enough about what
happens you know in the brain that
shapes uh social affiliations and
clearly clearly there's something
whether it's a football team whether
it's a group of friends whether it's a
political party our minds do work like
this and it's not only human Minds I
mean it's it's many other species social
creatures in general
a very very
um bound to this Dynamic of social
affiliation
um
hormones emotional responses are clearly
very very important in this and they're
important in general I think this this
just generally highlights something
that's still incompletely
understood and lacking when we think
when and people talk about the brain as
some kind of computer often and and
there's still this this
um hangover from
I think philosophers like Descartes and
the enlightenment who who emphasize
rationality as
this sort of ideal of of human mind and
what set us apart from from other
animals
but
our rationality is completely dependent
on on our emotional responses too
there's plenty of examples of that
people who who lack emotional responses
and they don't they don't make good
decisions we need emotional responses to
be practically rational
um
people like Antonio dimasio in my field
have been writing about us for decades
and it's it's abundantly true
and not taking into account the
emotional
um
responses of people is is a big mistake
in whatever sphere you're in you know
even if you're trying to understand the
brain as a neuroscientist you know we
have to think about the way I think the
way we experience anything is
fundamentally grounded in our body's
response to the situation our Nature's
living creatures is fundamentally
important to our experiences of the
world in the south
um and then you know back out into the
realm of society and politics
there's obviously a play on people's
emotions to drive these dynamics of
polarization
but this is often disguised right it's
often presented in the guise of of a
rational argument but really what's
going on is is a play on on emotions and
emotions of
of tribalism often because you talk
about you know it's important to have
emotion but if you were too emotional
you can't be rational either if you're
someone who feels emotions very
intensely then you get blinded by your
emotion
we'll see I don't I don't know I mean
there's this is again something we want
to look at a bit with this perception
census to try and understand how all
these different parts of the puzzle fit
together clearly at the extremes I think
you're right you know if you're just if
you just washed over by by Massive waves
of emotion breaking on you all the time
you're not going to be able to do very
much so like most things it's a balance
but downplaying or failing to recognize
the way in which emotion structures our
thought is
it is a big mistake and we shouldn't
aspire to get rid of this emotional
response right I think that's another
mistake people often think that I would
make better decisions or I'd be more
rational or be more effective if I could
suppress
my emotional reactions to a situation
and really think it through
and that's just I don't think the
evidence bears that out at all
and in fact it's not what people in
practice end up doing you most people
always go with
their gut reaction and what's a gut
reaction well that's that's a
recognition of the emotional
contribution is there not a difference
between like what you're talking about
which is intuition and like oh I'm
afraid and therefore I must do this or
or I'm angry and I must do this or I'm I
don't know horny and I must do you know
what I mean like isn't is there not a
difference between intuition
uh and my wife is very into this uh as a
lot of women are uh and uh like an
emotional reaction is there not a
difference between those two okay maybe
but also I think the Reliance on
intuition is definitely not gender
specific right I mean I think my wife
would disagree but that is so right
um yeah there's there's a difference in
in type but I'm not sure there's a
really fundamental difference
um what does that mean an emote what an
intuition to me is still an emotion it's
just an emotion that is it has a less
maybe a less immediate Target and it may
unfold over a longer time scale but it's
still it's still like a perception about
something you know this is good this is
bad that is
shaped in a large part by the brain's
response to the body
and an emotion of fear and anger is more
transient one would hope anyway and more
directly
um associated with a specific thing I'm
afraid of X I mean I'm
and uh
and so it's Contours maybe more easily
definable
but essentially
my intuition about this is how I
describe it because again I honestly I
don't think there's a there's a fact of
the matter but the way it appears to me
is that intuition and and fear and um uh
are just different
that's part of the same spectrum and
that spectrum is spectrum of how the
brain interprets a situation based on
perceiving its body's response to that
situation it's interesting you say that
because experientially I would very
strongly disagree with that like for me
in I've got a very powerful intuition as
well that I've used for to achieve a lot
of the things that I've been able to
achieve in life and to me it's very it's
literally the opposite of emotion if I'm
emotional about something I'm almost
certain to do the wrong thing whereas
intuitively if I if I have a a Karma
space to experience that sense that's
when I get the good stuff okay the good
advice and my wife likewise and I know
other people also who I've talked about
this that also have like to me intuition
is a deep knowing
an emotion is a is a reactive force that
is often destructive right I mean we
might just be using the words in
slightly different ways back to the
problems
that that you know a deep knowing
um
that that makes sense to me in some ways
but what I would still like to suggest
is that deep knowing is not sort of just
a an aspect of disembodied rationality
in the body too that's that's like
that's grounded it's definitely not
rationality because knowing is not
rational knowing is knowledge it's
there's no rationality too it's just
like you must do this or or you this
this would be the right thing to do yeah
I mean I think there's also something
interesting about intuition is that and
this isn't me thinking about it off the
top of my head now but intuition has a
kind of opacity to it right
if you can explain why you've come to a
particular decision then it's no longer
intuition correct um intuition depends
on an inability to unpack it into sort
of finer grained elements and that may
not apply so much to you know if I'm
angry and I do something then it's a
pretty transparent causal link right you
know I was angry so I did it although
even in these cases you know we may we
may miss attribute things if we may do
things because we think we were angry
but in fact there's other reasons
there's all sorts of old ethically
dubious psychology experiments from the
60s and 70s where people were
manipulating people's emotional
responses in particular ways to tell us
about that there's one I get the classic
one I mean I'm not sure it totally
illustrates the point the classic one is
um an experiment by
um
Dutton and Aaron he's two psychologists
in California in or in Canada western
Canada actually in the 1970s and they
were trying to make the point that
um the emotion we experience is
going to be it's it's the brain's
interpretation of what's happening in
the body
and so what they did was they got a
bunch of students to walk over a bridge
and this was kind of a scary Bridge it
was like a list of little rope Bridge
like Indiana Jones high above a
um a raging torrent and so it would get
the adrenaline going you know the body
would be put in in a particular
um State and at the end of the bridge
there would be it was all male students
and at the end of the bridge there was
an attractive female researcher who got
them to fill out a questionnaire and at
the end of the questionnaire and the
questionnaire was I can't remember what
it was that was sort of irrelevant but
the end of it there was a you know she
would say if you have any further
questions about the study here's my
number give me a call
and so there are a bunch of students who
went over that bridge there was another
bunch of students that went over like a
much less scary Bridge
um a couple of feet above the river nice
stable same thing and so what happened
was the students that went over the
scary Bridge of course A lot of them
called uh called the number
um and asked the girl out for a date
and the interpretation of this
experiment was that the the guys on the
rickety Bridge were misinterpreting
their physiological arousal caused by
the scariness of the bridge as a an
attraction with the with the girl and
that so they were they were
yeah that they'd been encouraged to
misinterpret the state that their body
was in as being something else
so that for me is kind of interesting
because it reveals that it's the emotion
that we have is not just a reflection of
the state the body is in but it's it's
it's deeply shaped by the context the
overall context that we understand the
body state to be in as well and that can
you know that that's a misinterpretation
right the reason the the person within
that state of physiological arousal was
because of the bridge not because of the
girl which brings uh to sort of start
heading towards the end of the interview
but you mentioned arousal and to take a
slightly deeper than that What is love
foreign
[Music]
like in terms of in terms of what's
happened I mean
is it is it a particularly human thing
that's one one question I'm not sure but
it's it's
um yeah I mean there's something
there's something very perplexing about
it because there's something almost
counter-intuitive about the depth
the psychological depth that that
emotion can have you know the
selflessness that it can bring about
whether it's the love of another person
a partner you know or a love of a
country it can lead to to behavior we're
trying to face of it is just a bit
perplexing on the other hand you know it
is it's what makes life worth living
and it's the most rewarding experience
that is possible to have quite why
our human psychological architecture has
such a special place for it I think is
is a bit mysterious clearly it's got
something to do with the fact that we we
generally pair bond and we need to bring
up kids and so on and you need some
psychological anchor to stop
new parents drifting apart and kids
Fanning for themselves and so on
um
so there's I think there is there is
probably quite good evolutionary
reason why we have this experience but
quite what it is and quite why it's so
different from other experiences that's
that's extraordinary I don't have a good
answer but I'm glad it exists
I know it's been a wonderful interview
thank you so much for coming on before
we do our questions for locals which
only they get to see we always end on
the same question which is what's the
one thing we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be
we've already talked about the one one
of these things which in this interview
which is the fact that we see the world
differently and I think most people
assume that's not the case the
implications of that are very important
the thing we haven't talked about much
today
and maybe fits into the the various Arc
of the topics we've covered is death
um we all die
um
until now this has been one of the great
equalizing forces in society one of the
things I worry about enormously is that
that may change and that
um with the amount of investment going
into life extension companies and things
like that it may soon be the case that
people at one end of the the Spectrum
not only have a lot more money during
their lifetimes but have a lot more
lifetime as well I think that would be
incredibly disruptive for society but
that's already True by the way to a
large extent I mean if you're wealthy
you probably live about 10 or 15 years
longer yeah yeah but I mean to me that's
still that's that's a minor difference
you think it's going to be 50 years 50
100 something like that 100 the
potential we don't know right but
there's there's there's that could
happen right if you want to invest in
trigonometry I want to live well I don't
want to live forever but an extra 100
years I'd settle for But but so that's
something I think yeah we need to take
seriously the the possibility of
something like that happening and what
is it what are the disruptive
consequences that you you fear well then
you just get this entrenched the set of
interests that that is common among all
people becomes smaller right you know
Society depends on some common process
that applies to all of us
and if you have some people who are
living a hell of a lot longer
their interests diverge a lot more from
people who don't have access to that you
go back to your real aristocracy and and
The Peasants yeah it's a pretty
dystopian situation
um just accompanying that though I think
in even in the current world in which we
live where we do all die there's so
little focus on that as as part of life
and I think we we neglect the end of
life in a way that's that's really
unfortunate for for society but for each
of us as individuals as well
foreign
we started talking a little bit about
anesthesia
um in a definition of Consciousness
anesthesia being its absence so anyone
who's had anesthesia kind of has a
little premonition of what it's like to
be dead you don't exist
and I I read a wonderful book a novel by
Julian Barnes the title is nothing to be
frightened of
and I think he means that in two ways
you know we're all frightened of
Oblivion but then Oblivion really is
nothing there's nothing going on and we
were not we're not worried about all the
time we didn't exist before we were born
but we are worried about the time
afterwards
and done coming to terms with with
mortality
is something that I think
is necessary and I think it's something
that is within grasp because a deeper
understanding of of the self that it
keeps changing that there isn't
an unchanging immutable essence of you
to cling on to
can give us a greater accommodation with
the prospect of not existing
and when we reach that that
accommodation I think
that enhances
the use we make of the days we do have
hmm
Anil it's been a wonderful interview if
people uh want to find you online if
they want to buy your book where's the
best place to do that
easiest place to find me is my website
which is
www.anilseath.com and the book being you
new science of Consciousness pretty much
everywhere it is everywhere even in
airports and everywhere you've done
really well man thank you and and if
anyone is Keen to help us with this
Research into perceptual diversity and
please take part in the perception
census and you can find that again on my
website
um or on dream
machine.perceptionscensus.world that's a
bit complicated just look at my website
Anil thanks for coming on thank you for
watching and listening we'll see you
another brilliant interview like this
one or raw show all of them go out at 7
pm UK time and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys see you on locals for the
bonus questions take care
do we have free will
this is a very good question
[Music]